- [Voiceover] So we
have been talking about
the Market Revolution
in the United States
which was this period in the first half
of the 19th century
where the way that Americans
did business really changed.
And it changed in a number of ways,
so the kinds of work
that people did changed
and the people they sold
their goods to changed
in the form of new markets.
And even the kinds of commodities
that they were producing.
All of these were
altered in the first half
of the 19th century,
thanks to a couple of simultaneous trends.
The Industrial Revolution
in which new technologies
were developed to make
production more efficient
and revolutions in
transportation and communication,
which made it easier
to get goods and people
to far distances more quickly
and to communicate over
considerable distances
more quickly.
And these really resulted
in a reorganization
of American society
that some historians have actually said
was more revolutionary than
the American Revolution.
So in the last video,
we discussed some of the new technologies
which changed American work
in the early 19th century.
One of these was the
introduction of the textile mill,
which was powered by a water wheel,
by Samuel Slater,
which helped textile mills
become the chief industry
of New England,
also helped women start
working outside the home
in the Lowell Mills,
started by Charles Lowell
and also began the system
by which factory owners
would hire individuals,
rather than family units,
to work for wages in their factories.
The other major invention that
had a really important impact
on American society was the cotton gin,
which was a machine that
separated cotton seeds
from the fiber and it made
the production of cotton
considerably more profitable.
And so, with cotton a profitable crop,
the American south
really invested in cotton
and investing in cotton
as its main cash crop
meant they really entrenched
the system of slavery.
So even though in the 1780s, early 1790s,
many southern states were thinking perhaps
they'd abolish slavery because
the institution was not
overly profitable,
as cotton became the
cash crop of the south,
the institution of slavery
would be entrenched
and continue to grow until the 1860s.
So those are some of the new
technologies of production.
In this video, I wanna spend
some time talking about
the revolution in communication
and transportation
that happened also in this time period.
So just like inventions
like the textile mill
or the cotton gin made
it easier to work faster,
inventions in transportation
and communication
in the early 19th century
also made it possible
to transport goods faster
and to transport information faster.
So I wanna talk about just a few
of these transportation inventions.
One of these was the railroad.
Now, the railroad was not
invented in the United States.
Rather, the United States
imported the railroad technology
from England and Germany
and this is one of the
very first railroads
in the United States,
I think it's kind of adorable
'cause you can see how it still is really
owing a debt, stylistically, to a wagon.
Even looks like a wagon here on the end.
So railroads begin to come
into the United States
in the early 1800s and first
they're mostly for cargo
or helping to move stone,
things to help build canals,
which we'll get to in a second.
But soon they're also
passenger rail stations.
And the Baltimore and Ohio Railroad,
or B&O railroad,
which you may know from
your Monopoly board
was one of the first passenger rail lines
in the United States.
Another major transportation revolution
of this time period was shipping on water.
So, in 1807,
inventor Robert Fulton
came up with the steamship
and so a steamship,
and you can see the little
smokestacks right here,
makes it much easier to power the ship
and one thing you can do
then is go against the tide
of a river,
so instead of just, for example,
going down the Mississippi River
to the port of New Orleans,
you can also go back up
the Mississippi River
which means commerce can go
more easily in both directions.
Another major innovation of
the time period are canals.
And this here is a map of the Erie Canal,
which was completed in 1825
and a canal is a relatively narrow,
relatively shallow waterway
but it still allows cargo
barges to move across
what otherwise would be really
hard to navigate territory,
so, you know, it's hard to see here,
but there are mountains here, right.
So, now you can take
cargo across mountains,
across large stretches of land by ship,
which is much faster
than trying to do it on foot
or with a wagon.
I think it's actually hard
for us to imagine now,
but in the early 19th century
and really for most of time before then,
waterways were the highways of the world.
It was a lot easier to
get from Boston to London
across the Atlantic by ship
than it would have been to get from Boston
to the Appalachian Mountains on foot.
Before the invention of air travel,
before the Interstate Highway System,
and really, up until the
invention of the railroad,
waterways were the
easiest way to get around
in the world.
And the last communication revolution
that I wanna talk about is the
invention of the telegraph,
which a portrait painter-turned-inventor
named Samuel Morse
first patented in 1844
and Morse invented Morse Code
because the telegraph worked by sending
pulses down copper wires
and so it made it easy to communicate
through coded messages of dots and dashes.
So, dots and dashes
corresponded with letters
which allowed you to send messages over
extremely long distances,
so you could send a message by telegraph
in an instant,
as opposed to sending a letter,
which might take days or even weeks
to get to its destination.
So, all of these revolutions
in transportation
and communication kind of translate into
two major transformations
in American business
at this time period.
One, is that the scope
of business that you
can do is much greater
because now, if you're
a farmer who lives in,
say, Rochester,
your radius of...
your radius of people you
can sell your produce to
before it goes bad is considerably larger.
Now, instead of just being able to get to
where you can get maybe in
a wagon's trip of a day,
you can send your crops on the Erie Canal
and suddenly, you're dealing
with a much larger market.
So, they're not only creating
a national web of commerce,
they're also creating an
international web of commerce
because these canals and steamships
go to international ports which mean that
you can now do business from
the western part of New York
with people who live in London.
And the other thing that increases here
is the pace of business,
right, so instead of having
to negotiate a business deal
through a series of letters,
which might take you many weeks,
now you can negotiate a business deal
by the telegraph
and it's only gonna take
you a couple of days.
Likewise, it might have taken you weeks
to send your logs for example,
down the Mississippi River.
Now you have them in a steamship
and it takes just a couple of days.
So there's an overall expansion
in the number of people who
can participate in markets.
The expansion of the distance at which
you can participate in a market
and the pace at which you can do it.
You can do business much faster
with these revolutions in transportation
and communication.
And in the next video,
I'll talk more about how
these transformations
in technology
and the scope and pace of
American business affected
the society of the United States
in the early 19th century.